[Musique]
et notre invité ce matin c'est l'ancien
président du Conseil constitutionnel
bonjour Jean-Louis devrait merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
étant ça pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Christelle
Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche bonjour
Christelle bonjour Oriane on va essayer
de parler de la Constitution on vous
reçoit aussi beaucoup pour ça j'en ai
Debré un constitution écrite par votre
père qui fête ses 65 ans va longuement
parler mais d'abord évidemment on
pouvait pas ne pas réagir avec vous au
décès de Jean-Pierre Elkabbach on l'a
apprière Jean-Pierre Elkabbache grand
évidemment journaliste politique
fondateur de cette chaîne publique c'est
là qu'est-ce que vous retenez
j'aime bien beaucoup connu
notamment quand j'étais président
l'assemblée que on a créé la Chaîne
parlementaire et le prix Sénat j'avais
eu des discussions avec lui importantes
puisque je voulais fusionner et qui est
qu'une chaîne parlementaire plutôt que
deux j'étais venu on avait fait une
réunion ici
une époque c'est une époque d'abord où
les politiques avaient quelque chose à
dire et donc il y avait ces grandes
émissions politiques avec ces Cabache
qui avait une connaissance de la vie
politique
des
arrières boutiques politiques et qui
posaient des questions c'était l'époque
aussi où face à ces grands journalistes
politiques il y avait des grands leaders
marchait
aujourd'hui
je retiens pas les noms tout le monde a
retenu et retient encore les débats avec
avec marchait les débat du politique
aujourd'hui pour vous mais oui cher que
d'abord un chez plusieurs phénomènes les
politiques n'ont plus rien à dire
il y a plus de débat idéologique il y a
très peu de période dans notre histoire
politique où il y a pas de grand
personnage qui émergent aujourd'hui il y
a personne comment vous l'avez pas
Emmanuel Macron pour vous quoi même pas
Emmanuel Macron aucun personnage quand
vous aviez
Mitterrand alors mission dominé la
gauche et la droite se déterminer par
rapport à Mitterrand quand il y avait
Chirac peu importe quand même j'ai un
dominé la droite et la gauche bon il y
avait des combats idéologiques
aujourd'hui le plus de combats
plusieurs choses
c'est d'abord je pense que les réseaux
sociaux jouent un rôle qui est médiocre
je pense en second lieu que la règle qui
a fait que un élu national ne peut plus
être individu parlementaire à écarté un
certain nombre de personnages je vois je
tourne au théâtre dans toutes les villes
et qu'est-ce que je vois je vois que un
certain nombre de
[Musique]
comment vous prépariez vos comment ça se
préparait une interview face à
Jean-Pierre
quand il m'a dit interrogé il y a deux
il y a deux Cabache il y a le Cabasse
qui écrit beaucoup de livres
et c'était une des rares
interview sur un livre par un
journaliste qui avait lu le livre
on est souvent interviewé par des
journalistes qui au mieux ont lu la
quatrième de couverture
là il avait lu le livre et donc il y
avait des savait très bien elle avait
coché des pages ou interroger ça c'était
donc il faut se préparer et en politique
il avait une telle connaissance de la
vie politique qu'on ne pouvait pas
raconter n'importe quoi et Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach c'est aussi évidemment le
fondateur Public Sénat on va parler tout
à l'heure de la place du citoyen dans la
Constitution et dans la démocratie mais
avec cette chaîne il a voulu faire
entrer la politique chez les Français il
a voulu rapprocher le citoyen des élus
c'était ça aussi ce qui animait
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach oui mais pas
uniquement avec pardon Public Sénat
l'époque car sur table je sais plus les
titres des émissions mais il y avait la
part du public qui ne soif de connaître
de connaître ses élus de
réfléchir avec eux
je trouve qu'on a plus cette soif et qui
a maintenant un désintérêt de la
politique
voilà et donc
elkabache restera à la fois un très
grand journaliste mais aussi un témoin
privilégié d'une époque à l'époque du
développement
cette époque révolue
de la Constitution Emmanuel Macron et ce
matin devant le Conseil constitutionnel
à l'occasion des 65 ans de la
Constitution écrite par votre père c'est
un peu la Constitution Debré de Gaulle
65 ans elle a dépassé en longévité celle
de la troisième est-ce que c'est une
forme de fierté pour vous cette
longévité parce que je me souviens
de ce grand professeur de droit qui
quelques jours ou quelques semaines
après le début de la cinquième
république annonçait que ça elle ne
durerait pas
et toutes les politiques de l'époque
disaient mais c'est fini on passe à la
Sixième République on entend ça depuis
65 ans mais
c'est effectivement comme vous l'avez
dit la constitution du général de Gaulle
de mon père mais c'est plus que ça c'est
une constitution qui a examiné le
fonctionnement de l'État et d'abord qui
a analysé les causes de l'échec de la
Quatrième République et qui a analysé
les causes de l'incapacité de l'État à
diriger la France et la volonté des
constituants et qu'on retrouve dans le
discours de Bayeux dans le discours
d'Épinal a été de faire en sorte que la
France soit un pays dirigé gouverné donc
c'est plus qu'un texte un projet
politique pour vous c'était un projet
politique qui est devenu une réalité et
le rêve d'un certain temps de personnes
c'est de revenir à l'ancien temps où le
gouvernement sous la Quatrième
République les gouvernements duraient
moi tous les six mois ont changé le
gouvernement dire que personne ne
dirigeait la France mais alors
aujourd'hui vous le disiez tout à
l'heure le monde politique a beaucoup
changé depuis la rédaction de cette
constitution les extrêmes n'ont jamais
autant de poids en France qu'aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'elle est encore adaptée à ce
paysage politique qui a été profondément
modifié notamment lors de l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron mais je trouve que
plus le climat politique est détérioré
plus ces institutions montrent leur
utilité
le pouvoir actuel
pourrait remercier tous les matins les
constituants de 1958
si ils ont traversé la crise des gilets
jaunes sans qu'il y ait en plus une
crise ministérielle c'est bien parce que
les institutions ont donné les moyens au
gouvernement
de diriger le pays
politique la crise démocratique est due
à la constitution de la 5e ou est-ce
qu'au contraire la Constitution de la
Cinquième à moins de riz la crise
politique aurait pu être beaucoup plus
grave sans un texte pareil
je pense que les institutions ont permis
à la crise politique de ne pas se
traduire par une crise gouvernementale
une crise de l'État c'est ça l'important
alors c'est vrai qu'on me dit souvent
la Cinquième République n'ont pas
permis d'enrayer l'abstention aux
élections mais je voudrais simplement
qu'avant qu'on examine les mécanismes
que les élus politiques étaient
s'interroge sur leur comportement
quand aujourd'hui on voit les débats à
l'Assemblée nationale quand on voit les
questions d'actualité quand on voit un
centre de choses on comprend pourquoi
les gens n'ont plus aller envie d'aller
voter c'est pas la faute du texte c'est
la faute du comportement des hommes
politiques actuelles tout évolue c'est
un texte quel qu'il soit il est porté
par des hommes et par des femmes ceux
qui ont des responsabilités alors faites
une distinction entre les institutions
et la pratique la pratique de tel
président n'est pas tel or aujourd'hui
on est dans une pratique qui est une
pratique qui je pense
n'est pas conforme à ce que les Français
attendent alors à l'époque ce que lui
reprochait ses adversaires à cette
constitution c'est de donner trop de
pouvoir au Président de la République à
l'heure ou partout en Europe montrent
les populismes est-ce que justement elle
ne donnerait pas trop de pouvoir à
quelqu'un qui se réussit de ces rangs là
on fait pas une constitution en fonction
de un tel ou un tel simplement ce que je
constate c'est que pour l'instant le
populisme de droite ou de gauche n'est
pas arrivé en France mais comme vous le
dites c'est préoccupant parce que dans
toute l'Europe il est en train de monter
et c'est quelle est la cause c'est pas
les institutions c'est ceux qui ne sont
pas populistes qui n'arrivent pas à
attirer la confiance des citoyens donc
ne mettez pas en côte c'est trop facile
de dire ce sont les institutions que
chaque homme et femme politique
s'interrogent sur l'image qu'il véhicule
je suis Catastro fait par le fait que
dans une réforme on a interdit aux
députés oscillateur d'avoir un mandat
local mais c'est une absurdité car
c'était
là où l'homme politique trouvait sa
légitimité en étant j'étais merdéreux
député c'était un complément fantastique
non mais pour revenir sur la question de
Christelle cette constitution elle n'a
pas été pensée pour des après mon
pouvoir est-ce qu'elle pourrait se
révéler dangereuse si les extrêmes
arrivent au pouvoir dans notre pays à ce
moment-là
du pays après c'est pas la
responsabilité des constituants c'est le
peuple qui choisit ses élus
la Constitution la Constitution c'est
quoi ce qu'elle permettrait
à la tête du pays
c'est d'abord un président de la
République qui a une légitimité
souvenez-vous chronicoti très sourde
scrutin pour élire il était lui aussi
fragile universel assure par son
fonctionnement
fonctionnement régulier les pouvoirs
publics et pour ce faire il a quelques
pouvoirs sans contre ça c'est ça le pré
deuxième
institution c'est le Parlement qui
donne au gouvernement la possibilité de
diriger le pays le gouvernement
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation et troisième avec
domaine là un artiste très précis que
l'article 34 qui délimite le domaine de
la loi le reste c'est de mettre
réglementaire et troisièmement un
conseil conditionnel qui veille à la
bonne architecture si vous voulez
pourquoi il y a une désinfection quand
vous regardez l'inflation législative
quand vous regardez la logorrhée
législative il y a de plus en plus de
textes les pagesja officiel j'ai
statistiques ça a explosé et on apprend
en plus
que bien souvent ces lois voter parce
que c'est devenu un objet de
communication politique ne sont pas
appliqués parce que le décret
d'applications ne sont pas et comment
voulez-vous que nous concitoyens aient
confiance dans ce système politique
c'est pas ce ne sont pas les
institutions c'est les hommes et les
femmes qui la pratique est-ce que malgré
tout Emmanuel Macron va s'exprimer ce
matin il nous annonce il annonçait hier
de grandes annonces justement sur la
modification de ce texte est-ce que vous
aimeriez qu'il évolue quand même sur
certains points est-ce que je sais pas
soit constitution et ça ça fait
cinq ans ou 6 ans qu'il faut des
annonces il annonce il annonce ça veut
dire quoi
notamment est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
serait souhaitable d'élargir un peu par
exemple à des sujets comme l'immigration
mais
peut-être qu'il faut je suis pas opposé
ouvrir le champ du référendum mais
attention
les constituants ont voulu une harmonie
entre la démocratie directe que le
référendum et la démocratie
représentative qui est le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale attention à ne pas
opposer les deux donc
[Musique]
il faut l'ouvrir jusqu'où alors ce champ
du rêve on peut on peut
l'ouvrir à des problèmes de société il
faut permettre un référendum sur
l'immigration sur la question migratoire
pourquoi pas oui pourquoi pas alors
attention si vous voulez tout ça ce sont
des mots parce que
l'utilisation des référendums depuis le
début de la cinquième république montre
que bien souvent nos concitoyens ne
répondent pas à la question posée mais
c'est une question de confiance à
l'égard du président etc ne créons pas
une instabilité d'ailleurs si on utilise
plus beaucoup de référendum c'est
justement à la suite de l'échec de du
référendum du général de Gaulle et celle
de Chirac qui ont fait que en région on
s'est rendu compte que c'était des
remises en cause du pouvoir alors on
peut faire évoluer je pense qu'il y a
des dispositions qui sont
nécessaires à ajouter mais attention
attention
on est dans un système ou grâce à René
Capitan qui était un gaulliste qui est
croyait à la suite d'un juriste célèbre
carré Malberg qu'on pouvait cohabiter
faire cohabiter le référendum et la
démocratie représentative mais attention
il y a un équilibre à trouver et ne
faisons pas trop de déséquilibre autre
sujet qui est sur la table depuis
plusieurs années notamment réclamé par
François Bayrou c'est la proportionnelle
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est la
connerie permettez-moi il y a pas un
pays au monde il y a pas un pays au
ou la proportionnelle a abouti à une
stabilité regardez la proportion de
l'intégrale en Israël c'est qui c'est le
petit parti au milieu religieux qui
gouverne c'est ça ce que veulent les
centrices comme il se dit qu'ils sont
plus de deux ils sont satisfaits ils
veulent être celui qui va en allant à
droite ou à gauche arrêtons donc c'est
intéressant
majoritaire a montré qu'il pouvait ne
pas y avoir de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale et qu'on
s'interroge quelle est la finalité d'un
mode scrutin
la finalité il y a deux finalités
la finalité ça peut être de donner une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale pour
permettre au gouvernement de conduire la
politique de la France et ça c'est
scrutin majoritaire dit anglo-saxons
plus ou moins fort premier taux un tour
de tour deuxième finalité à mode de
scrutin c'est donner une une image de
différentes tendances si c'est ça il
faut faire les élections tous les ans
parce que les Français changent de
coloration mais on sait très bien que la
proportionnelle aboutit à la
multiplication des parties d'autant plus
qu'en France
nous avons des règles de financement des
partis politiques qui avec la
proportionnelle
inciteront les parties à exploser et à
aujourd'hui il y a quand même une
demande de la population d'être mieux
représenté au Parlement
comment accède à cette demande il y a un
sentiment de la population de ne pas
être représenté parce que l'image donnée
par beaucoup de politiques n'est pas
l'image que les français reçoivent
encore une fois je pense très
profondément un qu'il faudrait
absolument que l'on revienne sur cette
incompatibilité entre la fonction de
sénateur ou la fonction
la décentralisation la place des
collectivités Emmanuel Macron était
encore la semaine dernière il a souhaité
que la Corse rentre dans la Constitution
ouvrant ainsi la voie à une autonomie
est-ce que vous êtes favorable
juriste magistrat c'est quoi je vous
répondrai invitez-moi le jour où le
texte sera précis
car qu'est-ce que c'est que l'autonomie
sans l'État mais pas contre l'État il va
falloir rédiger juridiquement ça comment
est-ce qu'on va rédiger c'est là où on
va voir la réalité on peut lancer des
mots oui on peut lancer des mots mais de
toute façon il y a des frontières qui
sont incontournables
la République est une et indivisible
c'est le préambule de la Constitution on
vous a remettra en cause unité de la
République
je vous je vous répondrai lorsque je
verrai le texte
la langue de la République est le
français l'emblème national le drapeau
tricolore bleu blanc rouge est-ce que
l'autonomie va remettre en cause
l'article premier et l'article 2 de du
préambule de la conscient de 1958 c'est
de la communication ce qu'a fait manuel
Macron pour vous je sais pas
moi je
j'ai entendu ça j'avais envie de
l'interroger dire mais qu'est-ce que
vous dites c'est quoi alors aujourd'hui
la politique c'est un métier de la
communication
on lance des mots autonomie etc et puis
après
moi montrez-nous le texte j'aurais
préféré qu'on le dise je souhaite
autonomie voilà le texte que je vous
propose justement vous parler de
communication est-ce que de la
communication ces nouveaux outils
politiques utilisés par Emmanuel Macron
je pense au Conseil national de la
refondation je pense se rencontrent de
Saint-Denis ou c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui peut faire avancer le débat
politique autre chose un attention de ne
pas jouer pour moi la loi notre règle
commune elle est faite par les
représentants du peuple c'est-à-dire des
femmes des hommes au Sénat à l'Assemblée
nationale qui ont reçu mandats du peuple
qui a voté
tous ces organismes que l'on crée ou on
tire au hasard ne sont pas l'expression
du peuple c'est l'expression d'une
loterie c'est l'expression un tirage au
sort et attention
le président qui rencontre chef de
partie
entre ces organismes
consultations on prend les gens au
hasard on étire au sort et le fait de
consulter les partis politiques je ne
vois là rien d'exceptionnel que le
Président de la République le Premier
ministre le ministre consulte leur
proposant des partis politiques merci
Jean-Louis Debré on dit un mot de votre
spectacle oui oui qui est en tournée ces
femmes qui ont réveillé la France oui on
sera dans quelques le 10 octobre à
Évreux puis après on va au Touquet
Toulon
ça fait deux ans qu'on tourne dans
toutes les villes de France et c'était
bon c'est un grand succès c'est c'est le
combat des femmes pour obtenir leur
liberté l'histoire est écrite par des
hommes mais l'histoire a été faite aussi
par des femmes on donne quelques dates
Évreux le 10 octobre et le Touquet le 22
octobre merci Jean-Louis devrait merci
beaucoup